there's only one way to say this the
creator of the famous VR headset Oculus
has claimed to have created a new
headset that has the capability to kill
a user in real life this story is
surprisingly real kind of fascinating
and slightly disturbing
[Music]
for those who don't know him meet Palmer
lucky the 30 year old creator of the
Oculus platform which produces VR
headsets and was bought by Facebook now
meta in 2014. in 2017 lucky left Oculus
and founded a defense contract business
revolving around military drones and
sensors and considering some of the
contracts he's been getting in recent
years have been around the one billion
dollars Mark a lot of people presumed
his VR days were behind him but last
weekend lucky posted something to his
personal blog which suggested the
contrary and a whole lot more the
November 6th post was simply titled if
you die in the game you die in real life
lucky began by outlining nerve gear a
fictional VR helmet seen in the Japanese
novel and anime series Sword Art Online
in this series a mad scientist uses the
headset to trap thousands of players in
the game which could only be escaped by
completing it if they run out of HP in
the game or their headset was tampered
with in the real world their brains
would be blasted with microwave and they
would die now that sounds like a very
Grim fantasy it is but lucky saw a lot
of parallels between that story and his
Oculus Rift he talked in his post about
how Sword Art Online led to public
enthusiasm for Oculus and that thousands
of people were reaching out to them to
ask if they could make nerve gear real
well not too long after that lucky
announced that quote the good news is
that we are halfway to making a true
nerve gear the bad news is that so far I
have only figured out the half that
kills you the perfect VR half of the
equation is still many years out yes I
am not making that up that is a direct
quote the good news is that they are
halfway to making the headset that
exists in Sword Art Online the bad news
is that they've only figured out how to
kill people so yeah halfway there now to
be honest I don't know this guy too well
I haven't really seen too many
interviews with him depending on his
sense of humor this could be a sort of
funny tongue-in-chi comment a bit of a
throwaway line or
well it could be a lot more disturbing
than that now you might be very quick to
dismiss all of this if you hadn't read
another section of the post where lucky
outlines his personal reasons for
engaging with this project lucky said
quote the idea of tying your real life
to your virtual Avatar has always
fascinated me you instantly raise the
stakes to the maximum level and force
people to fundamentally rethink how they
interact with the virtual world and the
players inside it pumped up Graphics
make a game look real but only the
threat of serious consequences can make
a game feel real to you and every other
person in the game this is an area of
video game mechanics that has never been
explored despite the long history of
Real World Sports revolving around
similar Stakes I think at the core of
the explanation is serious consequences
and Stakes lucky believes the maximum
enjoyment from a game comes from Maximum
reality and maximum reality can only
truly be achieved when facing real
danger while playing of course this
raises the question of when a VR
experience stops being a game for fun
and becomes a genuine fight for survival
he makes the comparison to Real World
Sports having similar Stakes but in the
real world athletes don't go into games
having genuine expectations of death as
a result of failure now to be Fair
perhaps lucky is talking here about his
headsets having the potential to kill
just like sports have the potential to
but that the vast majority of player
experiences with this headset won't
result in death at least that's what I
think but before we dive too far down
the ethics Rabbit Hole there I imagine a
lot of you guys are thinking at this
point in the video how exactly is this
thing supposed to kill a person in Sword
Art Online the nerve gear use microwaves
emitted at lethal levels which was
hidden from everyone in the project
except the mad scientist now lucky said
that although he is pretty smart he
couldn't come up with a way to make that
work but said that quote in lieu of this
I use three of the explosive charge
modules I usually use for an different
project tying them to a narrow band
photo sensor that can detect when the
screen flashes red at specific frequency
making game over integration on the part
of the developer very easy when an
appropriate game over screen is
displayed the charges fire instantly
destroying the brain of the user this
isn't a perfect system of course I have
plans for an anti-tamper mechanism that
like the nerve gear will make it
impossible to remove or destroy the
headset even so there are a huge variety
of failures that could occur and kill
the user at the wrong time this is why I
have not worked at the balls to actually
use it myself and also why I am
convinced that like in Sword Art Online
the final triggering should really be
tied to a high intelligence agent that
can readily determine if conditions for
termination are actually correct yeah
that's uh that's a lot to take in that
is a lot to take in this is like the
second or third time I've read this and
one thing I'm just noticing now is the
anti-tamper mechanism that makes it
impossible to remove or destroy the
headset what if the headset ends up on
the head of a toddler or a child or just
someone who didn't know what it was does
it have an override system are they just
supposed to be locked into the game and
potentially die this is wild this is
wild it is around this point that the
whole thing did start to feel like a bit
of a parody to me especially when he
said that he hasn't worked up the balls
to try it himself yet I mean that sounds
like the kind of thing you can only
really test once if we were in spring
right now I probably would have checked
the date of the blog post to see if
we're in April yet but lucky does seem
sincere about this perhaps the only
thing that seems to ground this project
in reality for me is Lucky's intention
to not sell this thing at least not yet
at the very end of the blog post he
refers to it as just a piece of office
art and a thought-provoking reminder of
unexplored Avenues in games design he
also added that as far as he knows it's
the first non-fiction example of a VR
headset that can kill a user but that it
won't be the last so even if this device
never leaves Lucky's office shelf he
believes that there is a future in it
whether it's he or someone else that
takes it up now I don't really want to
State the obvious here or burst the
bubble but I'm sure many of you guys
have had a similar thought already but I
can't really see this getting past the
first round of approvals with basically
any government on Earth we spend so much
time and money and resources making sure
that products do the absolute bare
minimum harm to the public can't really
see how one that intentionally does the
maximum harm is going to get through
there may be a deeper conversation to
have here about euthanasia assisted
suicide and the right to die but I don't
think gamifying these issues is going to
advance the debate I know we say this a
lot in our videos but I really would
like to hear your guys thoughts on all
of this on the device on the Creator I
feel like there's so much more to
discuss here I'll keep my eyes peeled
for any more blog post coming out from
Palmer lucky and until then I'll see you
all in the next one
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock
[Music]